Professor David Blight:
I was in a meeting some
months ago of the New York
Historical Society's Board of
Trustees;
august, wonderful group of
people.
That's about thirty-five very
rich New Yorkers and two token
historians, and I'm one of the
token historians.
They have us there for window
dressing, and other good and
useful and noble purposes.
And during a discussion of a
subject I won't even go into,
one of the very intelligent and
very dedicated members of that
board--and I'm not being
ironic--said that he really
wished American history could be
about "people of goodwill."
He wished American history
wasn't so full of conflict.
In effect, he was asking "why
can't we really just tell the
stories about people of
goodwill?"
And I remember thinking,
"Oh dear, this poor man."
But of course I didn't say
anything, kept my mouth shut.
I nearly threw up,
and I just went home,
about my business.
But why can't history just be
about people of goodwill?
I'll leave that to you,
to figure out.
Sometimes there is a great deal
of goodwill and sometimes there
isn't.
Now, Reconstruction is a
classic story of--we've said
this already--great change,
great experimentation,
change forced upon people in
some ways--as we'll see with the
Fourteenth Amendment in a
moment--and yet enough of a
cadre of leadership accepted
that challenge and rewrote the
country you live in.
And yet, of course,
like all great change,
it caused a tremendous--and if
there's a Newton's Law of
history--an opposite and equal
reaction.
Revolutions always cause
counter-revolutions,
just count on it.
Look throughout American
History just for a moment.
Let's play some games of
historical cycles just for a
moment.
Think of the greatest,
take your pick,
the greatest fundamental
changes in American History,
whether that's in society,
the law, politics,
massive immigration that
changed the demographics of the
country--take your pick,
but pick three or four of the
greatest moments of change in
American History.
Every one of them caused a
counter-change.
Every revolution we have causes
a counter-revolution.
You grew up reaping the great
changes of the Civil Rights
Revolution.
You take them for granted,
most of us do.
But you also came of age in the
midst of the counter-revolution
against it.
If you experienced the Civil
War and Reconstruction in
America, you experienced a
revolution,
in many ways perhaps even more
fundamental, than the one in the
'60's and '70s,
and you experienced very
quickly its counter-revolution.
Now, I just want to say that
because the more you read about
Reconstruction,
the more it seems to me you
find serious writers on
Reconstruction,
historians or otherwise,
and not a lot of popular
writers and journalists have
discovered Reconstruction.
We're going to read a book by
one of them, Nick Lemann,
who's the Dean of the
Journalism School at Columbia,
who in quite good ways fashions
himself a historian.
He always says he's not a real
historian,
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah,
but he did pretty good research
for this book on violence,
largely in Mississippi in 1875,
but he's using it as a window
into the counter-revolution
you're soon to be reading about.
But most people who write about
this period now tend to do it in
tones of a kind of a requiem;
a requiem, a tragic mode,
a mode that is always saying
what might have been,
what was attempted,
what was aimed for,
but then failed,
fell apart;
what high aspiration,
but God they couldn't quite do
it.
And it is a national requiem,
in a sense.
Somebody should write that
symphony, the Reconstruction
Symphony.
We need a Beethoven for that,
and he needs to be really
depressed one day.
But that doesn't mean it won't
be great and we won't learn from
it, feel from it.
All right, back on the ground.
I got in some cheap shots on
Andrew Johnson before we left
the other day,
and they were that,
cheap shots;
no apologies.
But Andrew Johnson's,
of course, a key player here.
He comes to the presidency
because he's Lincoln's running
mate, he and his office saying
he's going to make treason
odious.
And some Radical Republicans
were quite fond,
initially, of that approach,
but it quickly,
quickly changed,
and here in a nutshell--you've
read this now in Foner,
you've all gotten up through at
least the first four chapters.
And by the way,
I've now visited at least three
sections, and I'm enjoying it.
I wish they weren't just 50
minutes.
You just get going and--of
course this just gets going and
then--you're glad we're out of
here in 50 minutes I'm sure.
But back to Andrew Johnson.
He was, above all else,
an ardent States' Rightist.
He did not support Secession.
Now you can be a States'
Rightist, you can believe that
power should always remain in
the hands of the state and still
not believe in the right of
Secession.
And he was one of those.
He believed secession was
political suicide for the South,
and lo and behold he got that
one right.
He had a strong attachment to
the American Union.
He was a Unionist,
and a patriot in that sense.
He had a hatred also of the
Southern planter class because
he didn't grow up in it.
He was a poor boy who made good;
had a huge chip on his shoulder.
He was brilliant at a certain
kind of politics,
which was East Tennessee stump
politics.
Andrew Johnson,
it was said,
could crawl up on the back of a
wagon and hold an audience for
two hours, in East Tennessee.
He didn't very easily convert
that style and that talent at
local stump politics,
however, to the much broader
world of pragmatic negotiation
of Washington or the presidency.
He'd held every kind of office
you could hold.
He'd been mayor of Greenville,
Tennessee;
he'd been a state senator or
state legislator;
he'd been governor of Tennessee.
He was then elected Senator
from Tennessee and then once
again appointed the wartime
Governor of Tennessee by Abraham
Lincoln in the midst of the war.
He'd held every level of office.
He'd never been anti-slavery.
He saw the end of slavery as a
misfortune for the South,
something that had to be
accepted as a verdict of war.
But Johnson had one essential
slogan for his approach to
Reconstruction,
and if you can remember that
slogan you in essence have his
point of view:
the Constitution as it is and
the Union as it was.
The Constitution as it is and
Don't revise the Constitution.
He would accept the Thirteenth
Amendment, the end of slavery,
because that's part of the
verdict of the war,
there wasn't any way around
that, but he never accepted the
Fourteenth and Fifteenth
Amendments,
and he worked vehemently to
destroy the Fourteenth
Amendment, or at least he worked
vehemently to urge states not to
ratify it.
Now, his approach to
Reconstruction,
once in office,
was essentially this.
He took Lincoln's lenient plan,
The Ten Percent Plan,
and he went another step
further in its leniency,
or some say several steps
further.
Instead of saying he wanted ten
percent of the voting population
of the Confederate states to
take loyalty oaths,
form a government,
come back and so forth,
he simply converted ten percent
to,
quote, "that portion who are
loyal."
Any portion,
wherever may be two or more are
gathered, will have a loyal
government;
that portion who are loyal.
Now, he added one exception to
the pardons, however.
You remember people were going
to get pardoned,
lieutenant and above,
and so forth--I mean,
lieutenant and below in the
Confederate forces.
He added one exception to the
pardons, and this reflected a
very personal interest of his.
He would not pardon,
he said at first at least,
any Southerner who owned
$20,000.00 worth of property or
more.
It seemed like a class appeal.
Nobody who owned $20,000.00--
the planter class,
in other words,
was not going to get a pardon,
no matter what they did during
the war;
if they were rich they weren't
going to be pardoned,
well at least until they
applied for it,
and the application had to be
personal to the President of the
United States.
Now, this set in motion,
in 1865, a bizarre process.
He promised clemency but only
after they made formal written
applications about their new
loyalty.
And what literally occurred,
by the end of 1865 and
especially in the first months
of 1866,
is lines formed at the White
House in Washington,
often women.
Southern women came to--lines
outdoors, on a daily basis at
times--with their written
applications for clemency and
pardon,
for participation in the
Confederate war effort.
After one year of this process,
by May 1866,
Johnson himself had personally
signed 7000 such pardons.
He wanted to make them grovel,
in other words.
Not a wise policy,
but a policy nonetheless.
He did put in place,
or tried, some so-called
Johnson governments.
Now instead of calling them
Lincoln governments they would
be called Johnson governments.
And the reason Johnson could
get away with this,
of course, as you should know
from reading,
is that Congress went out of
session in the summer of
1865--for months,
they went out of session--and
Johnson had largely a free hand
to act,
and did he ever.
By December of '65,
when a new Congress would
reconvene in Washington,
all the states in the former
Confederacy,
except Texas,
had met the simplest of
criteria, had written new state
constitutions,
had found "that portion who are
loyal" to form a new government.
And it was very tiny
proportions in some places.
In fact, there were no loyalty
oaths, even applied to people.
All but one state,
Texas, was ready for
readmission to the Union,
under this--what actually Foner
calls it in his book--quote,
"amazing leniency of Andrew
Johnson."
The only major demand put upon
them was to formally nullify
their Act of Secession.
That's basically all they had
to do.
Now, these were whites-only
governments, these were
governments formed by former
Confederates,
and in many of these states,
of course, they began to
rapidly, in the late
summer/early fall 1865,
pass what became quickly known
as the Black Codes.
You've actually got a portion
of the Virginia Black Codes in
the Gienapp reader.
Three or four of those laws are
there in your reader;
read them, with some care.
These Black Codes mirrored the
old Slave Codes.
They explicitly denied the
right to vote to blacks,
the right to serve on juries,
the right to hold office,
the right to own property.
There were all kinds of
restrictive vagrancy laws
passed;
pass laws passed,
where blacks could be at any
given point in time,
with or without a pass.
And in this newly reconstructed
Johnson approach to these
states, there was a great deal
of legislation already flowing
from some of these new state
legislatures meant to directly
obstruct the work of the
Freedmen's Bureau.
The counter-revolution folks
began almost as soon as the war
was over, as soon as
ex-Confederates could find their
way into power.
And did they ever.
Part of what went on here in
the Northern mind--now let's
remember, the blood of the war
is not entirely dry--but part of
what was simply going on here in
the Northern mind as they
witnessed this,
and as these new states now
sent their representatives and
senators, after Fall election,
back to Washington,
some of them literally wearing
their Confederate uniforms.
And from Georgia came no less
than as the new U.S.
Senator from Georgia,
Alexander H.
Stephens.
A year ago he was the
Vice-President of the
Confederacy who had spent six
months in a Charlestown jail in
Massachusetts,
allegedly arrested for his
treason against the United
States, but released.
And as they began to arrive in
Washington, it was this kind of
insolence on the part of
ex-Confederates that in some
ways began to stimulate what we
will call Radical
Reconstruction.
Radical Reconstruction is a
plan.
And Foner's right on that.
He said one of the reasons that
this cadre of Republicans
succeeded is because they really
did have a plan.
If there's a revolution going
on and something's got to be
redone about your country,
go to the meeting with a plan.
James Madison did that,
by the way, at the original
drafting of the Constitution,
and he got most of what he
took.
But they came back to
Washington with ex-Confederate
generals, colonels,
members of the Confederate
Cabinet and the Vice-President
of the Confederacy.
Jeff Davis couldn't get elected
in Mississippi yet because Jeff
Davis was still the only
ex-Confederate still in jail.
He will never be formally
indicted.
He spent two years at Fortress
Monroe, in a prison,
in Virginia.
Tremendous mythology has gone
around that story that he wasn't
fed properly,
that he was mistreated,
that he got ill and wasn't
given medical attention,
virtually all of which is
nonsense.
He wasn't terribly well at
times but it wasn't because he
didn't get medical attention.
By the time the United States
Government, under the Johnson
Administration--in fact Johnson
wanted absolutely nothing to do
with trying Jefferson Davis--but
by the time they even got around
to finally formally considering
it,
they had wasted so much time
that Jefferson Davis will
finally be formally released in
the spring--April to be
exact--of 1867,
two years after his arrest.
And just to show you the
harbingers of reconciliation in
the political culture,
the people who paid his bail
were all Northerners,
some of them quite famous.
Horace Greeley,
the great editor of the New
York Herald-Tribune and the
former abolitionist,
although a strange and
mercurial character by now,
put up the most amount,
and none other than Garret
Smith--the former radical
abolitionist from upstate New
York,
who checked himself into an
insane asylum after John Brown's
raid--paid most of the rest of
the bail.
And Jefferson Davis would be
released, April 1867,
to a cheering crowd in
Richmond, Virginia.
He would go on to write;
to live in the South,
of course, and to write the
longest and most turgid,
the most overblown personal
memoir about a failed political
movement in all of history;
about 1300 page memoir,
basically all arguing that
secession was right and the war
wasn't about slavery.
Enough on Davis for the moment.
But back to Washington.
When these new state
governments send their
representatives to Congress,
beginning of December,
that's a Congress with an
obvious Republican majority,
and they absolutely called a
halt to the whole process.
Here were all these people from
the South coming to take
the--not loyalty oaths--but the
Oath of Office into the U.S.
Congress, and they were
stopped, some of them physically
at the door, and told to go
home.
And the Republican Party now
began to try to wrest control,
and they did wrest control of
Reconstruction away from Andrew
Johnson.
And from that day forward you
had the beginnings of a growing
Titanic constitutional political
struggle between president and
Congress--they are not of the
same party,
to say the least--that will
result in Andrew Johnson's
impeachment.
Now, to the Radicals for a
moment.
They established what was known
as the Joint Committee on
Reconstruction.
There'd never been such a
committee really in American
history before that date.
This was to be a committee of
members of both houses of
Congress, but they made no
pretence to bipartisanship.
It had 15 members,
12 of whom were Republicans and
three Democrats.
They said thank you very much,
we don't need any more.
Now, they established this
joint committee--it began to
meet in January of '66--the
purpose of which was to
investigate what was going on on
the ground in the South,
to investigate the necessities
and needs of Reconstruction,
to investigate the further
needs of the Freedmen's Bureau,
and to recommend to Congress
what legislation ought be passed
to reconstruct the country.
They held massive hearings,
the largest such Congressional
Hearings in American history to
that time.
They saw 144 witnesses over
about two months,
including Robert E.
Lee himself,
who came up from Richmond to
testify;
testifying essentially under
orders, and he still was under
House Arrest,
he didn't really have a choice.
They asked hundreds of
questions, but you could boil
them down to these.
They asked about the treatment
of freedmen in the South.
And their witnesses were all
kinds of people,
Union officers,
Freedmen's Bureau agents,
some white Southerners,
for sure, some famous,
most not.
They asked lots of questions
about the levels of loyalty and
disloyalty.
What were the political
attitudes of Southerners?
They were really trying to find
out "what would white
Southerners actually do if we
did that?"
Now, this was absolutely
crucial because we've long--I
wouldn't say assumed--but we've
long wondered,
and there's a lot of evidence
for this, that had the white
South in its prostrate state,
in its state of destruction and
defeat, had they truly been put
under an honest-to-God,
legitimate, near total
occupation, the assumption is,
among a lot of scholars,
that they (being the white
South), would've accepted it,
because they didn't have any
choice;
they had virtually no choice at
all.
And some of their leadership
was already in exile.
I think I mentioned the other
day about 8 to 10,000
ex-Confederate leaders,
mostly military people,
had left the country,
at least temporarily.
Anyway, they're trying to test
what Southern attitudes are.
Thirdly, they ask lots of
questions about the needs of the
Freedmen's Bureau,
what ought this Bureau do?
What about schools?
What about food?
What about hospitals, et cetera?
And then they would ask about
the need for troops and the need
for enforcement.
Now, you may know from reading
Foner by now that the reduction
in the Union Armies was
overnight,
from nearly a million men in
arms to a mere 15 to 20,000,
by 1866;
and a fair portion of those are
being sent west to fight
Indians.
And one of the great deep myths
about the melodrama of
Reconstruction,
or the Lost Cause version of
Reconstruction over the years,
is that the South was put under
this military occupation,
"bayonet rule," as it so often
was called.
About the only time a Union
soldier fixed a bayonet,
in all the Reconstruction
years,
was when they put their
bayonets on, in part to defend
themselves and go after the
people who were murdering and
massacring black people in
Memphis and New Orleans in 1866.
The vast majority of Union
troops throughout the
Reconstruction years,
in the South,
were simply in garrisoned
forts, on the coastlines,
occasionally in cities.
The conclusions of this report,
the Joint Committee's Report,
which was by the way chaired by
William Pitt Fessenden of Maine,
a moderate Republican senator,
but a key figure.
He had a lot of prestige.
He'd been in the U.S.
Senate forever.
He was an old-time Republican
but a moderate,
who had come to see the verdict
of the Civil War,
the destruction of slavery and
the challenge to make it good.
Their conclusions were
essentially this,
and they actually used this
word, that it would be,
quote, "madness" to let
ex-Confederates run the new
Southern state governments;
madness was the word used by
the Committee's report.
Secondly, the Johnson style of
leniency toward
Reconstruction--and they had
various ways of putting this and
various conclusions they drew
from this--was foolish.
And the third and last,
but not least,
they made a whole series of
recommendations for what they
called safeguards that would be
necessary to guarantee security
in the South and the beginnings,
at least, of a new political
regime in every state.
Now, it is that Republican
majority Congress of the winter,
spring and summer of 1866,
that began to first pass the
great legislation of
Reconstruction.
And if you want to see
Reconstruction as this rise and
fall requiem--and why not--this
is the rise.
If Reconstruction was a kind of
bright, shining moment,
as Du Bois once called it in
Black Reconstruction in
1935,
this was its moment,
1866 and '67,
when the actual system by which
the Southern states would be
readmitted to the Union was put
in place.
The first thing they passed was
the Civil Rights Act of 1866;
passed Congress in April of '66.
This was an act of Congress,
not a constitutional amendment;
therefore it didn't require a
two-thirds.
It was the first statutory
definition in American history
of the rights of citizenship.
It was potentially a profound
change in federal state
relations.
This Republican Congress and
its leadership,
at least, was going to do some
very new things with American
federalism.
Now, it had a bunch of flaws.
It gave full citizenship to all
Americans, regardless of race,
creed or color;
it said that,
the first time ever,
in our history.
We'd never had a citizenship
law.
It had never been legally
determined who was a U.S.
citizen.
But citizenship had always
implied whiteness,
and maleness.
It now had at least a
definition.
The problem in it,
of course its flaw,
and there would be a flaw and a
compromise element in almost
everything passed in these
years--nothing came out pure,
out of these terrible debates
over Reconstruction--its great
flaw was that it was directed
against public but not private
acts of discrimination.
I might still discriminate
against you any way I wish
privately, with my business,
with my private facility,
with my school,
with a lot of ways,
but in terms of public/civic
rights,
it at least put in place the
beginnings of the idea of
citizenship rights.
Secondly, this Congress renewed
the Freedman's Bureau.
They gave it a new life for
another year.
And they did this--and the
Civil Rights Act,
by the way--over the rapid and
quick veto of Andrew Johnson.
What set in as early as April
of 1866 was the Federal
Government by veto.
Congress would pass a law,
whether it's the Civil Rights
Act, the renewal of the
Freedmen's Bureau,
and numerous other
things--eventually all four of
the Reconstruction Acts in early
'67--and Johnson would veto
them.
Andrew Johnson,
in one and a half years,
will issue more presidential
vetoes than all American
presidents before him put
together.
Not the way the thing's
supposed to work,
but it's the way this was
working.
And then, for six months,
the Congress debated--and let's
remember, there's still about a
one-third of this Congress that
are Democrats.
I don't know how close I can
get you to this,
but I'm going to try,
at least to Section One.
Oh dear.
I don't know, can you read that?
Good.
Because that's the country you
live in.
Oh, I'm sounding so pretentious
today.
But you know what?
The United States was invented
at Philadelphia in 1787,
but in many ways--and Americans
still don't get this,
don't understand it,
don't know it--the country you
actually live in was invented in
1866,
in Washington,
D.C.
It's the country of the
Fourteenth Amendment.
The Fourteenth Amendment has
five parts.
It's the first one,
the resounding one,
the one authored by John
Bingham, a staunch,
Christian abolitionist from
Ohio, went to a tiny little
college called Franklin College.
It is that first clause that
actually revolutionized,
if you want,
the revolution.
The Fourteenth Amendment was in
effect the Republican
leadership's response to
emancipation.
Well of course the Thirteenth
Amendment is too,
but the Thirteenth Amendment,
you'll remember,
has a second clause that said
"Congress shall pass all
appropriate legislation,
to enforce it."
All right, now how do you
enforce the end of slavery?
What is the end of slavery
going to mean?
Or, as you were discussing in
sections yesterday,
and as Foner's chapter
addresses, what did freedom
mean?
What the amendment did is it
enshrined birthright,
and it enshrined at least two
things into the Constitution.
Even though they're ill-defined
at first and we're still
fighting over them right now,
in probably two-thirds of the
courts in the United States,
as we speak.
And by the way,
about two-thirds of everything
in an American Case Law Book is
a Fourteenth Amendment
case--those gigantic,
God awful thick case law books,
if you ever open one--about
two-thirds of everything in
there goes through the
Fourteenth Amendment.
Anyway, it enshrined birthright
citizenship, number one;
and number two,
the beginnings of the idea of
equal rights,
into the Constitution.
It took six months of debate.
It was passed finally in June
of 1866.
These were the new framers;
if you want, the new founders.
The first set of challenges
they faced, they've settled
pretty--not easily--but they
pretty much settled in clean and
clear language.
Those first three challenges
were number one,
to define citizenship and who
holds it.
Now, the Civil Rights Act had
already begun to do that;
this is going to go a little
further.
Two, they had the problem of
repudiating Confederate war
debts.
What do you do with all those
debts that a Confederate state
had entailed,
toward Great Britain or Spain
or France or anyone else?
The Federal Government was
hereby saying in a
Constitutional Amendment that
any debt the Confederacy had
entailed,
to any government,
any people, any bank,
anybody, anywhere--that the
United States Federal Government
would never pay them.
But they were also here trying
to head off, of course,
the demands for compensation
for loss of slave property,
as a Confederate debt.
And three, they had to face the
question now that every
Reconstruction plan to face--and
Lincoln had it in his and
Johnson had it and even the
Wade-Davis Bill had it--and that
is which ex-Confederates are
going to get disqualified or
disfranchised?
How many ex-Confederates?
What level of disfranchisement
would there be from office
holding, or for that matter
citizenship rights at all,
for ex-Confederates?
These three they settled,
but there were three others
they did not settle so easily,
and they were the extent of the
right to vote,
for black men.
Would this amendment declare
the right to vote for black men
everywhere, or only in the
South, only in ex-Confederate
states?
The inconvenient and terrible
problem on this one,
of course, is that the very men
writing this bill know that in
their own northern states black
suffrage is not popular,
to say the least,
and most northern whites still
don't want black men to vote,
especially in their own states.
The evidence of that was so
clear, the State of Connecticut,
this state, in 1865,
after the war was over,
held a special referendum and
overwhelmingly voted down the
right to vote for black men in
Connecticut.
Secondly, they had to settle
the extent of civil rights
declared equal before the law.
How equal?
Which rights?
Where?
That first section of the
Fourteenth Amendment ends with
the famous language of equal
protection of the laws.
No one shall be deprived--"no
state shall deprive any person
of life, liberty or property
without due process,
nor deny any person within its
jurisdiction the equal
protection of the law."
And then lastly they faced the
vexing problem now--and you may
have forgotten all about this,
it's easy to forget it--of how
to reapportion representation of
the so-called slave seats.
Those are the extra congressmen
that Southern states had been
given from the 1790s on,
through 1860,
because of the three-fifths
clause in the Constitution.
The estimate is that between
1800 and 1860,
the slave states in the South,
depending on when you take the
snapshot,
received from twenty to thirty
additional congressmen,
in the House,
because of the three-fifths
clause;
because three-fifths of black
people were being counted for
representation.
Now what happens is you're
going to count all black people.
The estimate was that the
Southern states would get an
additional eighteen more
congressmen.
So when these new states come
back into the Union they're
going to have more congressmen,
more power, more clout.
What are you going to do with
that?
Now, the key players in
this--and I want to spin through
this as quick as possible--the
key players in this were,
on the one hand Thaddeus
Stevens, as a kind of visionary
and radical voice.
Stevens would've had this
amendment go further than it
did, especially in Black
Suffrage.
Probably its greatest
architect--two of them
really--were John Bingham of
Ohio and Lyman Trumbull of
Illinois.
They're unsung heroes.
I bet you don't know anything
about John Bingham and probably
nothing about Lyman Trumbull.
They're not famous.
They should be.
Bingham wrote Section One.
Lyman Trumbull wrote the '66
Civil Rights Act.
He actually wrote the
Thirteenth Amendment,
and he will write other parts
of the Reconstruction
legislation.
John Bingham will stand up day
after day in the Congress and
will argue that Emancipation had
finally forced the United
States--this is the way he
always put it--to apply the Bill
of Rights to everybody.
And he argued,
in his words,
that what they were really
doing now, were federalizing the
Bill of Rights.
Now think about it.
American history had always had
the Bill of Rights.
Just tick them off,
the first ten Amendments to the
Constitution;
your right to religion and your
right to free speech and your
right to assembly,
and on and on and on.
But it had never been applied
to all Americans.
There'd never even been an
assumption it applied to all
Americans.
Well, there were others.
Charles Sumner, to some extent;
Robert Dale Owen of Indiana,
the old utopian community
leader, was quite a visionary of
this as well;
and some others.
But it's really a handful of
six or seven people,
who wrote the Fourteenth
Amendment.
Now, they faced tremendous
opposition.
Day in and day out Democrats
would get up and say that all
the Fourteenth Amendment really
was trying to do is to get white
and black people to marry each
other.
They trotted out the worst of
white supremacy and the worst of
racism to try to trash the
vision of the Fourteenth
Amendment.
It's going to have effect
eventually in a larger American
politics, rest assured,
because the '68 presidential
election is going to be a
referendum on this,
and it will be,
without question,
the most white supremacist,
racist election in all of
American history;
so unsubtle and so blunt that
it will surprise you,
I suspect.
The central compromise in the
Fourteenth Amendment--I'll let
you read the rest of its
provisions--but the central
compromise was actually on black
suffrage.
As I said, there was this
uncomfortable fact that most
white Northerners didn't want
black people to vote,
in the North.
So they left any enforcement of
the right to vote to the states.
They're going to codify the
right to vote for black
males--and by the way it's the
first time the word male got
into the U.S.
Constitution--a very
complicated, important
amendment, and it's going to
cause a terrible explosion and
actually a bad train wreck
between the Women's Suffrage
Movement and the old abolition
movement,
black and white men,
and it's going to cause
Elizabeth Cady Stanton and Susan
B.
Anthony and others to basically
bolt from the black suffrage
movement, and even the whole
Civil Rights movement,
such as it was during
Reconstruction,
and go off and fight their own
crusade.
That's another long story we'll
return to.
So instead of an outright
guarantee of the right to vote,
everywhere, for blacks,
men, the final version left
control of suffrage to the
states.
It did though,
in one provision,
penalize if a state,
to come back into the Union,
denied the right to vote to
black men, it would have its
representation in Congress
reduced to the proportion of the
black males in their state.
Now that's not going to scare
many northern states because
they don't have large black
populations.
And actually they're not going
to be part of that provision
because they never seceded from
the Union.
But the key thing here is that
the equality genie,
this language of equal
protection,
this definition of citizenship
rights, it had never happened
before, the equality genie was
now out of the bottle,
and for better or worse it
could never be put back.
The Equal Protection Clause is
the most malleable provision in
the Constitution.
It has been used to support or
advance the rights of everyone,
and everything,
every kind of organization you
can imagine, cities,
states, corporations,
immigrants,
women, gays and lesbians,
anti-gay and lesbian movements,
students, labor unions,
anti-labor union movements.
It has advanced tolerance and
intolerance.
It has advanced affirmative
action and the anti-affirmative
action crusade.
The Fourteenth Amendment is so
malleable it can be used by
anyone.
It's the great legal wellspring
of the modern Civil Rights
Revolution.
No Fourteenth Amendment,
no Civil Rights Movement.
And last but not least,
it is the basis of that
dreadful Supreme Court decision
in 2000 known as Bush v.
Gore.
I didn't make that up.
Now, in this circumstance,
of the passage of the Civil
Rights Act, the passage of the
new Freedmen's Bureau,
the passage of the Fourteenth
Amendment, now to be sent out to
the states for ratification,
comes the fall elections of
1866.
And Andrew Johnson took his
case out on the road.
He called it the Swing Around
the Circle.
The circle was to be the Union
or--oh, where's my map?
I have a better map here
somewhere.
Oops, no I don't even really
have the whole North on here,
sorry about that.
Oh well.
In the fall elections of
1866--these were Congressional
elections but they're terribly
important,
given what's going on in
Congress--the '66 Congressional
elections were a referendum on
Reconstruction and they came in
the wake of two terrible racial
riots or massacres in the South,
which really got Northern
attention.
The first was in New Orleans,
the other in Memphis.
In both cases they were
essentially police riots.
In Memphis, about forty blacks
were killed and over 200
wounded, whole neighborhoods
destroyed;
Congressional investigations
launched.
In New Orleans the riots or
massacre that was conducted by
the white police of New Orleans
against its black community was
stimulated by a political parade
of black Republicans in the late
spring, 1866.
Before the New Orleans riot was
over thirty-four blacks were
killed, about 250 wounded,
and hundreds of homes
destroyed.
This was the state of chaos and
reaction, already going on in
the South.
And you don't even really have
legitimate functioning
governments yet.
So out on the hustings that
fall the campaign appeals were
on the one hand by Democrats to
prejudice and racism and leave
the South alone.
Democrats are out on the
hustings blaming Republicans for
causing that violence in the
South--if you give black people
the right to vote,
if you let black people move
too high, too far,
too fast, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
And the Republicans attacking
Andrew Johnson,
for everything,
including his drunkenness at
his inauguration,
but most importantly for his
insolence and obstinance and
obstruction to Reconstruction.
So Johnson took his case to the
people.
He went on a long tour--he
called it the Swing Around the
Circle--all over the Northern
states,
up through New England,
all across the Midwest,
and he tried to be the old
stump speaker from East
Tennessee,
and it totally backfired on him.
He demanded that Ulysses Grant
go with him;
he demanded that William H.
Seward go with him,
the Secretary of State,
and they reluctantly joined
him.
They were, after all,
serving him as president.
Grant hated this.
Grant didn't even like politics.
He's soon going to have to
change his tune on that.
But what happened,
in essence, is that Andrew
Johnson went out and caused a
gigantic embarrassment,
for himself,
for Grant, and for others.
He took out hundreds and
hundreds of new U.S.
flags, that had thirty-six
stars on them,
and not the twenty-five,
without the eleven seceded
states, and he would pass out
the flags.
And everywhere he went he would
make the same speech,
over and over and over.
He would say you always begin
by saying, "I stand on the
Constitution."
And then he started talking
about the traitors in Congress,
he called them traitors,
Stevens and Sumner and Bingham
and Fessenden,
in their own states.
Now that wasn't very clever.
He even engaged in all kinds of
undignified displays and certain
kinds of vulgarity.
Crowds began to react to him.
He'd give the same damn speech
town after town after town after
town.
It'd be reprinted in the paper
and before he could get up and
say, "I stand on the
Constitution,"
the crowd would start saying,
"Yeah, yeah,
yeah, you stand on the
Constitution."
Crowds started shouting back at
him saying, "Shut up" and "Stop"
and "We'd rather hear Grant,"
and chants of that sort.
It became, in some instances,
by the time he got to the
Midwest, into Indiana and
Illinois, impossible for him
even to hold an audience.
Then finally he started to
compare himself to Jesus on the
cross;
never a good idea.
[Laughter]
He was being crucified by the
radical, traitorous wing of the
Republican Party and Congress.
And then he invented a story
that he had been the one called
Judas, and he worked that,
he worked the Judas metaphor,
about as often as he could.
He was finally shouted off the
stage in Pittsburgh and he just
took the train and went home.
He also kept referring to this
magical circle of the Union;
magical circle of the Union,
and it became a parody.
And in the fall elections,
the people of the Northern
states returned an overwhelming
majority of Republicans to the
Congress;
a slightly more than two-thirds
veto proof majority,
to the Congress.
And it will be that Congress,
once it convenes in December
'66 and into the next winter of
'67,
that will put in place the
first Reconstruction Act,
and then three subsequent
Reconstruction Acts to enforce
the first.
And that first Reconstruction
Act we will come back to next
time, because it's crucial.
But it set up here--and you can
see it on this map--a system by
which the South was to now be
divided into five military
districts,
two or three states in each,
the ex-Confederacy divided into
five military districts,
each commanded by a
major-general.
That major-general was to have
control over elections and
electoral boards,
and a sufficient body of
troops,
it said, to enforce the
electoral process in the South.
And there was to be,
according to that first
Reconstruction Act,
as we'll see,
a high level of Confederate
disenfranchisement.
This now will be the Republican
Party taking control of
Reconstruction,
of trying to plant the
Republican Party into the South
now with African-American votes,
and they will succeed in
creating Republican control,
legislatures,
governors' offices,
in all eleven of the
ex-Confederate states--at least
at first--and in some of those
states we'll see some remarkable
experimental democracy put in
place,
unprecedented,
to that time,
in American history.
Unfortunately,
of course, what will also be
stimulated and put in place is a
deeply embittered reaction in
the white South,
to now do whatever it took--by
any means necessary--to destroy
the Republican party,
to destroy African-American
autonomy, to destroy the
African-American right to vote.
And it will be organizations
like the Ku Klux Klan,
which had been around at least
since 1866 but are going to
explode with fury in 1868.
And between 1868 and 1871,
the Klan and its many,
many, many imitators will
engage in a kind of
violence-as-real-politics,
in an attempt to take back
control of the political South.
And I'll leave you there
hanging, with good will.